dancing with POI well that's just
impossible that's something only people
who are really coordinated or really
talented can do right not so fast there
are actually tons of poy dance moves
that don't rely on you knowing your plas
from your FES and even better they use
tricks you probably are already familiar
with and I'm going to share five of them
with you in this video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and in this video I'm sharing with you
some of my favorite po dance moves for
beginners but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys pyara
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission dancing with POI can
seem really intimidating if you've never
done it before lots of us who get into
po don't really have a background in
dance or other movement Arts so learning
to move the rest of our bodies to the
music can be a huge Challenge and yet
I'd bet you'd be surprised by how easily
you can put together simple concept
Concepts that make your POI and your
dance sing together in harmony so let's
find out how and if you like videos on
PO spinning and flow Arts be sure to hit
the Subscribe button and ring the bell
so you know right when I drop a new
video now on with the show move number
one over and under curves this is
actually a technique my dance teacher
used to give us in class that pairs
super well with any poy trick that has
the hands moving around together
learning the technique is pretty simple
too you stand with your feet shoulder
with ap part and bend just your right
knee taking your hips over to the right
then you bend your left knee to bring
your hips back to Center but at a lower
level than you started at next you
extend your right knee while keeping the
left knee bent to move your hips over to
the left and finally you extend your
left knee to return to where you started
so Al together you bend your right knee
bend your left knee extend your right
leg and extend your left leg if you
perform this continuously you'll find
your hips move around in a
circle this is a perfect compliment to
any poy trick that takes the hands
around in a circle for starters you can
use it with windmills or tuck turns and
eventually work your way up to fountains
flowers and even hybrids for such a
simple move it can add a lot of flare to
your flow check out some examples before
and after here's that windmill before
over and under curves and here's that
windmill after see how moving your hips
makes your whole body seem to move with
the poy around in a bigle Circle or how
about a fountain here's before and
here's after once again this one simple
change can make a world of difference in
how the move appears I think that when
most people think dance though they
think of things that involve moving
their feet so with that in mind let's
take a look
at move number two
two-steps the two-step has a long and
proud tradition is one of the first
pieces of footwork that many aspiring
young dancers learn so let's see if it
will work with po to do a two-step put
your feet together and count off in your
head a simple beat 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 step
out with your right on one and bring it
back on two step out with your left on
three and bring it back on four so let's
try it 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 keep your weight
centered over the foot that is not
stepping so you keep your balance when
you step out you can tap either your
toes or your heels depending upon the
effect you're looking for you can step
forward to the side or back depending on
the effect that you're looking
for there's lots of ways to add po to a
two-step but one of my favorites is to
use a butterfly or a thread the needle
you can stack a new hand on top with
every count if the PO are short or use a
bigger extended Circle to match the hand
with the foot stepping out but the
utility of of two-steps doesn't end
there here's a small selection of Po
moves that you can perform them with try
using a two-step with a 3B weave
performed in wheel
plane or a set of pendulums to either
side or stalls to either side too there
are no shortage of possibilities here so
now that those feet are moving let's see
what we can do about getting them to
move you around a little
bit move number three pivot
reels the footwork for this was my
favorite warm-up in the first hip-hop
class I ever took it can take a little
practice to get down but I think it's a
fabulous way for beginners to start
working their way across a stage you'll
start this off facing to your stage
right step on one with the left two with
the right three with the left and pivot
on the balls of your feet around to face
the direction you just came from on four
now stepping toward stage left you'll
once again step on one with the left two
with the right three with the left and
pivot on four Step 1 2 3 pivot 1 2 3
pivot left right left pivot left right
left pivot this keeps us contained in
one specific part of the stage but still
gives us the capacity to move around and
explore the space a little bit so what
do we do with our POI while we're
walking back and forth I'm so glad you
asked one of the simplest answers is
just to spin the poy at your sides in
wheel plane first spinning forwards
together and then when you pivot to
switch directions spinning backwards
together simple yet
effective but if you're ready for a
little bit more of a challenge try doing
this with a 3B weave instead you perform
a waist strap with every pivot to switch
from weaving forward to weaving reverse
and Back Again feel free to style this
out a bit there's plenty of room to make
this move your own so make sure to
express yourself awesome so now that
I've got you moving around with your POI
let's see what happens when we let our
POI take off
move number four Potter shot
butterflies Leaping Lizards things have
gotten serious I'm using French and
everything I swear this isn't as crazy
as it looks though pot of shot just
means step of the cat to ballet in
modern dancers and I'm willing to bet
you already do this and don't even know
it you know how when you step over a
fence or a baby gate you step one foot
at a time to clear it a pot of shot is
the same idea you're just imagining
someone is passing the fence or baby
gate under you and you're more or less
just jumping in place one foot at a Time
start this off by jumping up with your
right leg and before it can touch the
ground again you jump up with your left
to follow it think that you'll jump
right left and then back left right
that's all there is to it I love doing
this with a reverse or outward butterfly
because I feel like the movements
complement each other think that as the
PO comes up through the middle you're
going to start the jump with your first
foot and come back down by the time the
PO do leap to your right and then to
your left if this seems a little
challenging feel free to take a moment
in between jumps to get your bearings
again of course my favorite version of
this involves just a little bit more
exaggeration and style but I think it's
also quite a bit prettier as you make
your leap open up your arms into to
Broad extensions to increase your volume
when you land have your second foot
crossed behind your first to create a
more pleasing silhouette that's it two
minor tweaks and you get a much prettier
move if I do say so myself we're closing
in on our final beginner po move and
it's got to be a crowd pleaser so what
could possibly top all these other
beautiful po moves move number five the
backbend buzs saw so I'm guessing half
of you watching were hoping this was
going to make the list and the other
half were afraid that it was going to
but let's put away those torches and
pitchforks for just a moment because I
think this move is actually a really
important one backman buz saws get a lot
and I do mean a lot of grief from pois
Spinners who Pride themselves on the
difficulties of the tricks that they
tackle to them back bend Buzz saws are
overly simple and what's worse they
actually work crowds love them and they
take very little work to learn or
perfect they feel like cheating but do
you know what they call it in most Arts
when a simple technique gets a big
response out of an audience useful
rather than having to kill yourself
constantly in a performance to keep the
audience engaged moves like this give
you the option of maintaining an
audience's attention and getting to take
a breather while you do it back bend
Buzz saws work because they give you a
level change and a degree of proximity
to the poy that the audience finds
really impressive what's not to like go
for extra points by taking it down to
your knees groundwork is always a hit
with a crowd so now that you've got all
these awesome po dance moves to choose
from as a beginner let's see all of them
in action
[Music]
a
and if you'd like to deepen the
knowledge you gained from this video
with some helpful drills and exercises
is you should check out the flow Circle
the flow circle is an exclusive weekly
lesson available only to my patreon
subscribers this month I'm sharing
exercises designed to help you improve
your POI dance skills everything from
different footwork exercises to an
intensive on poy turns and Petes all to
get you moving and feeling confident
with the props sooner sign up over at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy the first
lesson is available now so I hope this
helps many of you out there get closer
to discovering your inner dancer if you
got anything out of this video please
make sure to like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find it
thank you
[Music]
kindly this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen y'all Rock and if you out there
watching are not currently supporter but
you're interested in becoming one you
can sign up for my patreon over at
patreon.com drexfactor poo or the card
that just popped up on screen there you
can get access to a host of awesome
resources and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and the flow Arts to the whole
wide world every little bit helps so
please take a look and if you're hungry
for more po dance moves I did a video of
my top five favorites that I'll link to
down in the description as well as up on
screen who knows maybe you'll find a new
favorite too either way thanks so much
for watching make sure to go outside and
flow yourself today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace